foreign
a computational notebook is an authoring
environment where code is interspersed
with natural language
many people call this style of computing
literate coding
using this method
authors can render their reports
dynamically as part of the code's
execution
as such
a report is an expression that can take
many forms some examples include PDF
document a web page an interactive
dashboard
a Word document or a slide deck
using a computational notebook we
combine data inputs code
and computational outputs with
explanatory text to generate multimedia
documents
the outputs become the artifacts
documenting a body of work
it is often recommended for reproducible
workflows to do as much as possible with
code
in other words
derive reports from code
this practice decreases typographical
errors
avoids inherently idiosyncratic Mouse
clicks such as copy and paste
and orchestrates workflows as a
reproducible process
to accomplish this
we use code notebooks to mingle pros and
code chunks within the same document
as such visualizations or other
computational actions are derived from
code chunks and displayed in line
the combination of these elements are
rendered dynamically into reports
if the data changes or the code is
updated the code notebook is Rerun and
the reports are re-rendered
by intermingling code with natural
language authors clearly explain data
models and workflows as a process
this reduces the dependencies on outside
and undocumented steps another
reproducible practice
one example is a quarto notebook a
visual computational notebook that
evolved from the legacy of our markdown
quarto notebooks support multiple
computational languages python R Julia
and observable Js
Corto notebooks can be edited and
composed within Visual Studio
Jupiter notebooks command line
or the r Studio IDE
in summary
computational notebooks are reproducible
authoring environments designed to be
easy to read and easy to compose
a quarto notebook is an open source
practical application of the literate
coding concept
with minimal practice authors can use
notebooks as a convenient and
reproducible approach to documenting and
executing workflows
thank you